[Música]
[Aplausos]
da igual que hablemos de la Guerra Fría
el proceso de construcción europeo las
principales instituciones globales de
nuestros días tienen el mismo Punto de
partida 1945 la victoria aliada en la
Segunda Guerra Mundial el momento más
decisivo de todo el siglo 20 este
megaconflicto supuso un antes y un
después para la geopolítica global Dando
forma desde entonces a lo que ahora
entendemos por relaciones
internacionales sin embargo mis queridos
amigos de visualpolitik hoy día en 2023
hay señales de que podríamos estar
acercándonos a otro de esos momentos
decisivos pensadlo por un momento la
caída de la unión soviética generó
entonces la ilusión de una época
dominada por Estados Unidos que era la
gran superpotencia económica y militar
quizás fue verdad en los años 90 pero la
crisis económica de la gran recesión de
2008 y el desgaste sufrido en Irak o el
fracaso colosal en Afganistán han puesto
muchos problemas al imperio americano
sacudido además internamente por la
extrema polarización política generada
por el trampismo y sus oponentes vamos a
decirlo claro a veces parece que Unidos
no parece por su mejor momento y claro
la pregunta Es evidente quién Podría
tener interés en aprovechar esta
aparente debilidad creo que todos tenéis
la respuesta la Rusia de Vladimir Putin
como principal heredera de la unión
soviética Rusia conserva un Arsenal
nuclear temible Desde el kremlin no
dejan de recordarnos que el apoyo de
occidente Ucrania no va a salir gratis
el expresidente ruso medevez advierte
que estamos más cerca que nunca de la
tercera guerra mundial y está aumentando
el riesgo de una hecatombe nuclear ahora
bien Europa del Este no es el único
lugar donde los intereses
estadounidenses están en peligro Corea
del Norte continúa amenazando a Corea
del Sur y Japón Kim Jong se niega a
negociar su programa nuclear con
Washington y continúa probando misiles
Como quien se aprobó unas camisetas otro
tanto puede decirse de la República
islámica de Irán que está a un solo paso
de enriquecer uranio al nivel necesario
para fabricar armas nucleares según los
inspectores de la agencia atómica de la
ONU pero esperad un momento porque ya
sabéis que si en la última década hay
alguien que se ha convertido en el mayor
quebradero de cabeza de Washington no es
ni Rusia ni Corea del Norte estamos
hablando de China
[Música]
Pekín ha invertido un pastizal en su
ejército ya reforzado su poder nuclear y
como os explicamos hace meses en otro
vídeo La gran obsesión de chiclingpin es
la anexión de Taiwán Aliado
estadounidense y clave en el mercado
mundial de semiconductores tampoco
podemos olvidar que la influencia china
se ha extendido mucho más allá del
continente asiático y que sus relaciones
con Moscú atraviesan por su mejor
momento Así que el mundo continúa
cambiando y no precisamente a favor de
Washington Así que para evitar que el
nuevo Imperio Romano de occidente caiga
otra vez entre los bárbaros la Casa
Blanca tiene mucho que aprender de la
época clásica atentos quien desea la paz
debe prepararse para la guerra Flavio
vejezio siglo cuarto tener unas fuerzas
armadas imponentes serviría para
disuadir a todos los enemigos de que se
pusieran a actuar Así que en la Casa
Blanca ya se están preguntando si el
ejército estadounidense cumple con esta
función y si está preparado para hacer
frente a todas estas amenazas por lo
tanto ahora la pregunta es En qué
situación están actualmente las fuerzas
armadas de los Estados Unidos cuáles son
sus principales puntos fuertes y dónde
podrían encontrarse sus debilidades hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
una modernización pendiente
vamos a decirlo claro las fuerzas
armadas de los Estados Unidos son como
el París Saint Germain del mundo militar
con mucha muchísima diferencia nadie
gasta tanto en defensa ahora bien la
pregunta es toda esta pasta que se pulen
cada año se está invirtiendo donde
realmente se necesita o no y aquí las
opiniones discrepan la historia nos
muestra que el ejército estadounidense
se renueva cada 40 años lo hizo entre
los años 30 y 40 del pasado siglo en los
albores de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
también lo hizo entre los años 70 y 80
cuando entraron en el servicio las armas
que llevaron al ejército estadounidense
a la cima del poderío militar son las
conocidas como las Big Fight y estoy
seguro de que habréis oído hablar de
casi todas ellas el tanque abrams el
vehículo de combate de Infantería
Bradley el helicóptero de ataque Apache
el helicóptero utilitario Black hope y
el sistema de misiles patrio Pues bien
tras la caída de la unión soviética y
con el mundo en relativa paz el
pentágono inició a finales de los años
90 una serie de programas innovadores de
renovación del armamento con lo que
nadie contaba es que en un solo día el
futuro cambiaría para siempre y diréis
pero de estamos hablando pues hablamos
por supuesto del 11 de septiembre del
año 2001
los ataques terroristas contra las
Torres Gemelas y el pentágono llevaron
al presidente George Walker Bush a
iniciar dos guerras prácticamente al
mismo tiempo las operaciones militares
de Afganistán Irak fueron un éxito al
derrocar en unas pocas semanas a los
talibanes y al régimen de Sadam husaín
sin embargo las tropas estadounidenses
quedaron atrapadas en dos conflictos
interminables contra diversos grupos
armados algo que ha exigido continuos
recursos humanos y económicos y ha
supuesto un enorme desgaste político
[Música]
según el proyecto costo Word de la
Universidad de Brown Las Guerras de Irak
y de Afganistán han consumido más de
cuatro billones de dólares Así que a
medida que ambos conflictos enquistaban
los mandos militares se vieron obligados
a renunciar a superar más del futuro y
centrarse en cambio en sacarle el máximo
partido a las Big Fight que ya tenían
por el camino se quedaron programas de
modernización Como por ejemplo el
crusader llamado a ser el novus
autopropulsado de Nueva Generación que
tanto necesitaba la artillería
estadounidense pero esperad un momento
porque si hay un proyecto que fue un
auténtico fiasco Ese fue el de Future
Combat systems los futuros sistemas de
combate
lanzado en 2003 por la administración
Bush Su objetivo era crear nuevas
brigadas equipadas con nuevos vehículos
tripulados y no tripulados conectados
entre sí para actuar de una forma rápida
y flexible sin precedente alguno el
ejército de Estados Unidos aseguró que
era su mayor y más ambicioso programa
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial sin
embargo la administración Obama decidió
cancelarlo como parte de un cambio de
estrategia enfocado a gastar más en la
lucha contra el terrorismo y menos para
prepararse ante una guerra convencional
contra grandes estados como podrían ser
China o Rusia nada como este titular del
año 2011 para que os hagáis una idea de
Hasta qué punto fracasó la modernización
del ejército estadounidense atentos
informe del ejército las fuerzas armadas
han gastado 32 mil millones de dólares
desde el 95 en programas de armamento
abandonados como os podéis imaginar
nadie sale anunciar un fracaso como este
y se queda de brazos cruzados el primer
mandamiento de la comunicación política
es siempre ofrecer una alternativa para
desviar la atención
en este caso para reemplazar algunos de
los cometidos del fallido programa
futuros sistemas de combate se diseñó el
programa Brown comebackle es decir
vehículo de combate terrestre Su
objetivo era desarrollar un vehículo de
combate blindado de Última Generación
para reemplazar al Bradley pero el
ejército canceló también este programa
cinco años después debido a las
restricciones presupuestares
introducidas en 2011 y así hasta hoy
porque relevar al dichoso Bradley
continúa siendo una auténtica máquina de
triturar billetes atentos el ejército
gastará al menos 1500 millones de
dólares solo en prototipos para el
tercer intento de reemplazar el vehículo
de combate Bradley en el año 2011 la
administración Obama aprobó la bca es
decir la ley de control presupuestario
que tuvo consecuencias notables para el
presupuesto del departamento de defensa
dentro de los esfuerzos de la Casa
Blanca para reducir el aumento del
déficit tras la gran recesión de 2008
esta ley de control presupuestaria
estableció topes de gasto durante 10
años por lo que ha estado vigente hasta
el año 2021 no ahora el momento de
discutir si esta ley era necesaria o no
pero sí podemos decir que ha sido todo
un obstáculo para la modernización del
ejército estadounidense tal y como
durante todos estos años queda reflejado
en noticias como esta el gasto en
defensa debe superar los límites de la
ley de control presupuestario para la
modernización nuclear según un informe y
claro si en todo este tiempo el
pentágono no ha hecho los deberes y las
amenazas no han dejado de crecer estos
dos hechos combinados nos indican que la
no hace tanto considerada como la gran
superpotencia militar Podría tener
algunos problemas si los acontecimientos
se precipitaran en contra de sus
intereses y diréis pero de qué tipo de
problemas estamos hablando Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
una herencia insuficiente
hace 6 años Donald Trump dio un nuevo
giro a la estrategia de seguridad
Nacional de los Estados Unidos en este
caso la Casa Blanca volvía a enfocarse
hacia la preparación de un supuesto
megaconflicto contra las grandes
potencias enemigas a saber China y Rusia
y sí Este cambio ha sido respaldado
también por Joe biden Y por supuesto por
Vladimir Putin la guerra de alta
intensidad ha vuelto tal y como nos ha
enseñado la invasión rusa de Ucrania
Pues bien la fundación heritage elabora
cada año un informe en el que se evalúa
el estado actual de las fuerzas armadas
de los Estados Unidos ahora mismo se
está prestando un apoyo brutal a Ucrania
un apoyo cifrado en más de 27.000
millones de dólares tanto en equipos
como en suministros militares reponer
los inventarios Será muy complicado
según Dakota Boot que es el responsable
del informe de la fundación
segunda cotabud Estados Unidos ya ha
proporcionado Ucrania un tercio de sus
misiles antiaéreos stinger así como más
de un millón de proyectiles de
artillería y un tercio de su reserva
total de misiles antitanque
si os parece que esto no es un problema
pensad que esta escasez de existencia se
está dando simplemente prestando ayuda a
Ucrania imaginad lo que exigiría un
conflicto directo contra un gigante como
china Bueno en realidad no hace falta
que os lo imagináis porque ya hay varios
expertos elaborando informes al respecto
atentos la industria armamentística de
Estados Unidos no está preparada para un
conflicto con china según un informe y
respecto a las fuerzas armadas el
informe de la fundación heritage
considera insuficiente la capacidad de
los cuerpos militares estadounidenses
para cumplir con las misiones que tienen
encomendadas el informe se refiere
fundamentalmente a una cuestión de
tamaño en cada conflicto importante
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial Estados
Unidos movilizó el equivalente a 21
brigadas de fuerza terrestre el cuerpo
de Marines aproximadamente 15 batallones
y la fuerza aérea de alrededor de 600
aviones de combate en este sentido la
fundación heiditage considera que para
asegurar los intereses estadounidenses
lo recomendable es tener una fuerza de
al menos el doble de grande esto
supondría que el ejército de tierra dis
pusiera de 42 brigadas cuando
actualmente solo tiene 31 los Marines 30
batallones cuando Ahora solo tienen 22 y
la fuerza aérea 1200 cazas cuando
actualmente apenas tienen la mitad
Asimismo la armada requeriría de 400
barcos cuando su número ya ha bajado de
el informe de heritage recuerda que en
los años 80 la Marina tenía casi 600
barcos de los cuales permanecían
desplegados aproximadamente 100 en 2022
el número de embarcaciones desplegadas
se mantenía en unos 94 pero la flota
total ha disminuido a 298 con previsión
de reducirse a 280 en 2037 la misma
carga de trabajo sobre una flota que es
menos de la mitad significa que apenas
hay tiempo para el entrenamiento la
preparación y el adecuado mantenimiento
y renovación al estar continuamente
operativos
y un problema similar existe en la
fuerza aérea según la fundación
hateritage durante la Guerra Fría los
pilotos de combate promediaban más de
300 horas de vuelo anuales actualmente
no llegan a 120 horas Así mismo el
ejército de tierra opera con brigadas
pero enfoca su entrenamiento a un nivel
mucho más reducido de compañías
asumiendo que lo haga un combate todo se
también y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
algunos vale muy bien Fonseca Pero esto
es lo que dice la fundación que es un
poquito neoconservadora y quiere estar
preparada para dos guerras al mismo
tiempo no crees que exageren un poco
pues hombre cada uno que piense lo que
quiera pero Mirad lo que argumento ante
el senado el almirante Richard que es el
comandante del Comando estratégico de
Estados Unidos hasta su retirada el
pasado mes de diciembre atentos
anteriormente había enfatizado nuestra
necesidad de poder disuadir a dos
adversarios al mismo tiempo esa
necesidad es ahora un imperativo tienes
que disuadirlos todo el tiempo no me doy
el lujo de dar la prioridad a uno y
menos para el otro tienes que hacerlo
todo al mismo tiempo almirante Richard
es comandante del Comando estratégico de
Estados Unidos mucha gente piensa que
invertir en defensa Es una pérdida de
dinero ya que estaría mejor destinarlo a
programas sociales porque nunca pasa
nada mejor invertir en hospitales que en
balas Pero bueno quizás nuestros
espectadores de Ucrania podrían darnos
una opinión un tanto distinta al
respecto actualmente el presupuesto de
defensa de Estados Unidos asciende a más
de 800.000 millones de dólares veamos
ahora cuáles son sus grandes apuestas
[Música]
prepara la cartera otra vez
estamos todos de acuerdo en que el
panorama internacional ha cambiado
radicalmente en el último año Rusia
invadió Ucrania y China cada vez amenaza
más a Taiwán los enemigos de Estados
Unidos están pasando a la acción y en el
pentágono lo tienen claro la
modernización del ejército
estadounidense ya no se puede aplazar
más Mirad lo que dice el general James
mcconfield que es el actual jefe del
Estado Mayor del ejército de los Estados
Unidos
actualmente una de las grandes apuestas
del ejército estadounidense es el futuro
vehículo de combate opcionalmente
tripulado se está invirtiendo muchísimo
dinero ni más de más y porque claro
opcionalmente tripulado significa que
este vehículo podrá operar de forma
Autónoma una tarea que nunca se ha
logrado hasta ahora y que nadie tiene ni
idea si se conseguirá ni Cuánto costará
una estimación eleva las ci hasta los 46
mil millones de dólares lo que podría
acabar siendo toda una Revolución
militar o un fracaso de dimensiones
Nacho vitalianas ahora bien la gran
apuesta del pentágono es el f-35 que ya
sabéis que es el caza de combate con el
que pretenden dominar los cielos y al
que ya hemos dedicado un montón de
vídeos aquí en visualpolitik y en
nuestro canal hermano mega projects Tío
Sam prepara la cartera otra vez porque
este juguete es de los carros el
pentágono agrega 14.000 millones de
dólares al coste total del caza f-35
hasta los 412.000 millones de dólares se
van a adquirir 2.400 f35 Así que cada
uno saldrá por unos 160 millones de
dólares que para que os hagáis una idea
es un poquito más de lo que le costó
dembélé al Barça en ambos casos Aún está
por comprobarse si tanta inversión
mereció la pena
[Música]
en cambio Si hablamos de la armada el
programa que ya está confirmado como un
fracaso es el de Los buques del combate
litoral que se están empezando a retirar
apenas 13 años después de entrar en
servicio por sus elevadísimos costes de
operación al necesitar casi el doble de
tripulación de lo previsto ahora se
pretende enmendar este fracaso Nacho
italiano con la fragata lanzamisiles de
la clase constelation la primera fragata
no llegará hasta 2026 y el programa ya
acumula 2000 millones de dólares de
sobrecostes hasta los casi 11.000
millones de dólares en total Pero bueno
la frase más repetida en el pentágono es
la misma que en Parque jurásico no hemos
reparado en gastos atentos efectivamente
Estados Unidos gasta en defensa más que
los siguientes 10 países que más gastan
juntos pero es que la modernización
requiere de muchísima inversión de hecho
uno de los ámbitos que pide a gritos
modernizarse es el de sus fuerzas
nucleares habéis oído bien durante años
y han limitado a extender la vida útil
de sus equipos actualmente el pentágono
está desarrollando el sentinel que es su
nuevo misil balístico intercontinental
que debería operativo en 2029 de no
tener éxito Este programa Estados Unidos
verá reducida su capacidad de disuasión
nuclear Mientras tanto a nivel político
La Apuesta del presidente Joe biden es
el aucus
es una alianza militar entre Australia
Reino Unido y Estados Unidos El pacto
tiene en su punto de mira a la armada
China la más grande del mundo aucus
busca incrementar la implicación de la
casa blanca y Downey Street en los
asuntos del Pacífico de este modo los
Estados Unidos y el Reino Unido ayudarán
a Australia a hacerse con una flota de
al menos 8 submarinos de propulsión
nuclear capaces de operar con mayor
alcance resistencia y sigilo
el nuevo enfoque hacia china está
aumentando considerablemente la
inversión de los Estados Unidos en la
región del Pacífico se acaban de aprobar
87 mil millones de dólares hasta 2028
que el comando de lindo Pacífico piensa
destinar a nuevas armas construcciones y
a cooperar con los aliados en la región
una de las prioridades es la de reforzar
la defensa de la isla de One defendiendo
la base militar estadounidense de UAM
lockheet potenciará el sistema de armas
aegis para neutralizar los misiles del
ejército chino el misil chino de f-26 es
conocido como El asesino de One así que
todo lo que instale Estados Unidos para
defender la isla de One está más que
justificado pero ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que el ejército
estadounidense estará preparado para
enfrentarse ante un eventual conflicto
con China y Rusia o pensáis que nunca
habrá un choque directo y que sería
mejor dedicar tantos millones de dólares
a otros asuntos podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]